[موسيقى]
بس ولا واحد يموت ولا واحد يصير فيه حاجه
نبني بيت غيره
[موسيقى]
رامي المصري سكان بيت لاهيا كنا بامان
الله موجودين ببيتنا
معنا اطفالنا
وزوجاتنا فجاه صوت من الجيران بنادي
اطلعوا واخلوا البيت بدهم يقصفوا البيت في
لحظه من الدعر والخوف والرعب
زين كان نايم حضنته طلعت فيه ادم ابني
الثاني
طلعت فيه قلت ناديت يابا يما بسرعه اخذوا
الدار بدهم يقصوا الدار الجيش الاسرائيلي
اتصل على جيراننا بدهم يقص في الدار
زين صحي بقول بابا ايش في ايش مالنا مالك
شايلني بقول له يا بابا ولا اشي مش يعني
مش عارف ايش اعبر للولد الطفل يعني الصغير
طب احنا بنفس الوقت احنا بنهول الصدمه
حملنا حالنا حافيين والبنات يعني بالشارع
موقف صعب جدا جدا
[موسيقى]
حذرونا باتصال عن طريق جيراننا انه اخلوا
البيت والبويت والمجاوره لانه
الانفجار حيكون ضخم طلعنا احنا على الشارع
ضربوا صرف الزنانه ثلاث دقائق اربع دقائق
كان صاروخ الاف 16
مدمر البيت كله البيت اصبح قومه من الركام
قومه من الحجار فقدنا كل شيء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
خاص على الساعه ثمانيه وعلى الساعه 8:20
تقريبا
احنا الجيش الاسرائيلي بدنا تبلغ اللي هو
انس المصري
بازاله البيت على اساس ايش يهدمه والحزل
قالوا بس بدنا نهد البيت
حكيت له
وقف شوي انا بالراحه على اساس انه بس احنا
نطلع يعني في اولاد صغار وفي بنات وبعدها
ضرب صاروخ زنانه
في الاخلاء واحنا بدانا ايش نجمع في اهل
الحاره جماعتنا كلهم طبعا هذه الدار فيها
بيجي خمسين نفر 60 نفر وهذه الدار واحنا
بيجي عشره 15
اليوم احنا اصبحنا ماوى بلا مكان
حاليا زي ما انتم شايفين احنا بالشارع
موجودين انه احنا مواطنين زينا زيهم بشر
زينا زيهم لا بدنا اكثر ولا اقل بس بدنا
نعيش بكرامه بدنا نعيش بحريه بدنا نعيش
باستقرار بدنا نعيش الطمانينه الطفل
الزنبو احنا كبرنا وتربينا وشق عمرنا تعب
سنيننا بنينا لبيوتنا ووسعنا حالنا وربينا
وتربينا في البيت وبدنا نربي اولادنا
واحلامنا واحلام اطفالنا كلها كانت تحت
سقف هذا البيت فجاه البيت اصبح وكان
[موسيقى]
حاليا احنا موجودين بالشارع شويه حنوزع
حالنا ايش عند جيراننا حكم مساحه البيوت
انه العدد كبير فبدنا نوزع حالنا ولحد
بدنا نشوف ايش بده يصير بعدين يعني بدنا
الليله بخوف ورعب
زين عنده حصاله عيديته ومصروفه وبحوشه
شيكل شيكل حتى يشتري سرير لاله نفسه سرير
اليوم الحلم
تبخر ما ضل حلم بيت احنا كنا مستقرين فيه
امنين مطمئنين اليوم بلا ماوى اليوم بيتنا
كان بيت يعني حاضنه لكثير من الاسر فترات
التصعيد يعني كان يوصل عنا خمسين شخص من
كثر الامان اللي احنا كنا فيه وكانوا
مامنين الناس يجوا عنا نحتضنهم واحنا حتى
يعني بدايه تصعيد كنت اتصل على جيراننا
ونسايبي تعالوا عنا لانه احنا كل تصعيد او
كل مواجهه بيتنا امن اليوم بيت الملجا
اصبحنا بلا ملجا
[موسيقى]
اول حاجه ضرب
ت بس ولا واحد يموت ولا واحد يصير فيه
حاجه نبني بيت غيره وكنت
[موسيقى]